foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined this hour my
best-selling author Christina Ellis and
we are taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life your
money whatever is on your mind whatever
ails you hopefully we can help you take
the right Next Step Rachel joins us up
first in Seattle Washington Rachel
welcome to the show
hello there and how are you guys today
we are doing well how can we help you
I am
really
um doing baby steps and stuff and I am I
have some medical or some dental major
down to work coming up and I'm wondering
if I should pay for that before I do my
thousand dollar
um
emergency fund
well tell us a little bit more about
your situation how much debt do you have
right now
um the best that I know of right now
it's about
well
for uh well no maybe fifty three
thousand dollars
and what is that made up of
um mostly
um about 36
000 in student loans
and then
um
about
uh four thousand been medical debt and
um and then first about
Sharif two to three thousand in in
current Consumer Debt and then the rest
of it's old old old debts into things
okay speak directly to your phone Rachel
we're having a slightly hard time
hearing you
sorry when I get embarrassed I get quiet
there's no reason to be embarrassed
you're doing so great and we're going to
guide you through this so tell us your
income
um I expect it to be
about 33 000 this year okay and you're
single
yes okay and tell us a little bit more
about the medical procedures on the
horizon you said it's some dental work
how much yeah how much is that gonna
cost
about ten thousand dollars
and
um it's
um so I had to have some dental uh some
I've had a lot of medical over the last
three years
um I didn't have medical insurance for
jobs a years and so walked in with hip
issues ended up with cancer and that was
just kind of the start of the journey
over the last three years and so
um but one of the things is I hadn't
done a lot with dental and so they I've
had the number of teeth pulled but
there's some of it where they're not
have more teeth pulled and they had to
reconstruct some stuff on my jaw
and so I have to so if I don't put in
some implant an implant in one place
then I'll end up with having to have
some other teeth pulled I've got a
couple teeth that need work and even
with insurance it'll be ten thousand ten
thousand out of pocket Rachel that
sounds that sounds overwhelming sorry
you've been going through it
yeah and so how long have you been
listening to the show
uh well recently probably the last
couple months and
a couple decades a little decade and a
half or a couple decades ago I I mean I
did FPU I did I got myself all other
debt except the student loans and then
and
then a lot of Life circumstances and got
off track and and so and you've been
through it you've been through it and I
think with you here now you've had your
I have I've had it moment right like
this all yeah feels overwhelming
okay because it's gonna take some
radical effort and changes to get out of
this mess and to also pay for the
medical but I think you're ready for it
yeah how much money do you have in the
bank Rachel
okay and how how soon is this procedure
happening
um that's so the two teeth if I don't
want to lose them and have a and and
haven't increased more each of those
need to be done ASAP and I just had one
of them chip another piece off so that
it needs to be done and then the other
thing I've got one to
um phase one meets is scheduled for for
the end of May and then phase two is
um I have a basically a year to do it I
have to heal up for about three to six
months and then I I will do that next
year we don't need to come up with 10
grand up front is what I'm hearing we
can do this in pieces and stagger it
yeah so how much do we need for the next
one that ones that are Urgent how much
money
okay so we need 2400 saved within the
next few months is there a payment plan
they put you on have you explained your
situation to them
and
when it comes to Denver
then want to go more into dad and that's
have you gotten a second opinion from a
different dentist
yes and what'd they say
and it was it was the same and they're
also unwilling to work with you
yeah yeah well Rachel I'm wondering
there's a number of places that'll say
well we'll pull it and that'll be
cheaper but then it destabilizes the
mouse and then I have have you know it's
like yeah the short term but yeah anyway
so you've been through all this medical
stuff you've had all these challenges
how are you feeling physically now are
you able to work out of the house are
you able to work a full-time job
ish I have to take off one to two days a
week for medical okay
um I am a tax preparer so most of my
income is earned right now so other than
doing the two Dental things I am trying
not to do more medical than I have to
right now although I'm in physical
therapy for a couple types of physical
therapy and you know I can I can go down
the road but all of that to say that it
is a lot and there's yes there's a lot
going on
I'm looking longer is is problematic too
yeah I'm looking at your income and it's
pretty tight and with this procedure
coming up I'm just trying to think
through different ways you can raise
some more money to be able to afford
these procedures maybe there's you know
something you can sell
um if you're physically able to maybe
able maybe you can get another another
job work a little bit of extra but with
33 000 I know that things have got to
feel really tight especially with the
debt payments
yeah and one thing I should say is that
my mom
um allows me to live with her there's
you know she's there's a bunch of
stuff without without having to pay rent
so that's okay yeah we need to lower
your expenses as low as possible
increase your income as much as possible
bust it preparing those taxes so that
you can create this money to pay for the
medical so we're gonna put the baby
steps on hold right now our job is to
stack up as much cash as possible and
take care of your health then we'll get
to the rest of the debt so take a pause
but go hard at creating this pile of
cash to get you through this I'm so
sorry it will get better Rachel we are
here for you let us know if we can help
in any other way this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour it's a free call at
888-825-5225 well Christina as I was
Doom scrolling on Instagram as I tend to
do I saw this post from ESPN pop-up and
here's the big headline a record 50.4
million U.S adults are expected to bet a
combined 16 billion dollars on this
year's Super Bowl whoa just take that in
for a second
16 billion dollars 50 million Americans
that is a large percentage of the entire
population
now at first I went okay that's crazy
but then I went wait aren't these the
same people complaining that inflation
is too high and there's not enough money
at the end of the month and they're
living paycheck to paycheck and so that
was my post my reaction was Americans
inflation is killing us we're living
paycheck to paycheck out here also
Americans oh yeah bro I got 500 bucks on
the Chiefs
make it make sense that's all I'm asking
this just boggles my mind that people
are willing to spend their hard-earned
money and just throw it away at a sports
Casino for fun so here's the
juxtaposition Yahoo finite Finance said
that half of Americans say their
personal financial situations are worse
now than they were a year ago which is
more than any time since the Great
Depression and Fox Business said amid
High inflation Rising interest rates
credit card balances have now increased
to 931 billion dollars in the final
quarter of 2022. this is insane the
number of new credit cards have uh
opened have spiked 21.6 million dollars
in the third quarter I mean
the levels of debt with the levels of
sports betting tell me that bad things
are happening out there yeah that's very
concerning it makes me wonder is is it
kind of like the lipstick for men you
know how like what they say whenever
there's a recession like women buy more
lipstick yeah like sports bat more I
guess that's what they do to to you know
quell all the anxiety is they just turn
to sports and then they go well my
friends are better it's now normal to
bet on Sports there's a thousand apps
and yeah okay let's see if Mahomes gets
the touchdown and the you know in the
third quarter it just doesn't make sense
that's wild I thought it was more of a
niche I thought it was like you know
sports betting there's probably two or
three percent of people but 50 million
people every year it's become legal in
more and more States I think it's like
33 States now allow sports betting and
here's the thing they're seeing record
profits it's like the new crypto because
it feels not as dumb as crypto because
it's something that you enjoy that you
know a lot about but these bookies that
are behind the scenes they are going to
win The House Always wins this is just
like Vegas except you get to do this
from the comfort of your freaking couch
it's wild too because we've seen so many
studies and stats on kids and teenagers
getting into this where it's like young
kids I don't think they're really
supposed to but it's becoming a huge
thing in high schools where we're
worried about kids doing sports betting
which that just blows my mind and the
bankroll you need to even make any
amount of money in this is insane you
would need to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars to see any
meaningful return but what happens is
you throw 50 bucks you lose it you put
another 50 bucks in you might win it
back and so there's an addiction
happening especially with these young
people it's like the gateway drug to
gambling addiction and here's what's
crazy the number of expected Super Bowl
Bettors is up 61 percent from last
year's survey
and uh our sort of state of personal
finance study uh found that in the last
three months 14 of people said they had
placed a legal Sports bet it begs the
question how many place the legal Sports
bets we just don't know no one's gonna
admit that but 36 percent said they lost
money in 20 2022 sports betting and
that's equivalent to five percent of the
population having lost money on this
George what would you say that just
hurts my head a little bit thinking
through all the people who are
struggling with their finances and all
the people who feel like they're
drowning in credit card debt but they're
still betting what would you say to snap
people out of that well number one if
you are really struggling like truly
struggling now I'm hoping and praying
that the people that are sports betting
are out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund and they're investing 15
and this is just fun money they're okay
blowing if that's you I am happy for you
the the record indicates that is not the
case and so if this is you and you're
going this is my last my last ditch
effort uh let me at least have some fun
I'm broke might as well at least have
some fun you're only going to get broker
and so we need to stop the bleeding and
go anywhere there's money leaks we need
to stop there are better ways to be
entertained and blow 50 bucks than on
the big game and on the squares and it's
just gotten out of control and so just
say no go to the party uh you know bring
a dip it costs you five bucks and enjoy
the Super Bowl that way but do not play
in this Sports Casino you will lose the
house always wins and there's a reason
why Vegas is doing so well and America
is so broke
it's a good word George oh my goodness
and we've covered you know sports
betting on multiple multiple areas
multiple shows uh Rachel Cruz show we
did a thing on sports betting if you
want to see me in a Brady Jersey you can
check that out hopefully he's retired
for the last time we just don't know we
do to be determined oh well I enjoy the
big game do it on a budget and don't be
stupid
hope that hits
the word let's get to the phones Charles
is in my hometown there in Massachusetts
Charles welcome to the show how you
doing
thanks I want to speak to you too you as
well how can we help
um okay uh basically I've I've screwed
up my life I know that
um and I don't see any way out of it I
don't know how to even start or what way
to go but my my student loans are 150
000 and they're not coming down and um
my house payment my house mortgage is
120 000 and so since my house is less
than my student loans when you do a dead
snowball do I pay off the house first
and then the loan but either way it's
it's going to be years before I can even
come close to paying off anything and
then how do you do something like that I
got kids at home how do you do something
like that and not find yourself singing
Cats in the Cradle in a few years well
Charles who told you that your life is
over
well it's it's like I can I can try I
don't see any way of paying this off you
know
um what's your income uh at least let's
put some facts on paper
uh okay uh I take home
um my household income is maybe 45 to 50
000 depending on if I can get overtime
and that's the most I've ever made in my
life okay
um right now I'm a mechanic at a
amusement park out here I was lucky that
they gave me that job what's your degree
in you said you have 150 in student
loans
yeah I have a degree in elementary
education and uh Masters in school
administration
okay and how old are you and I'm 48 my
wife's uh 53 and she's not able to work
or drive or anything
does she have any disability income
yeah she has a disability but but she
gets um about a hundred dollars a month
in Social Security that's all she was
able to get but my other daughter who
lives with us is disabled and she gets
about eight hundred dollars a month so
that's what's saving us basically well
Charles you've called the right place we
like calls like this because we have
seen thousands of people in situations
like yours with six figures in debt get
completely debt free
so first of all your life is not over
you have not screwed up so bad that you
can't come back from this you absolutely
can we actually have a personality that
joined recently who paid over four
hundred thousand dollars in debt off
and we've seen that multiple times so I
just want to encourage you that you are
in the right spot and if you're willing
to fight for it you can get out of this
and also just with the student loans you
said that it's 150 and it's not going to
come down I believe it's going to come
down pretty quick you're you're educated
I think your income potential is pretty
high right now you're 45 and 50 and I
think we can really bump that up
um but yeah I think first just getting
out of the mindset that this is too
desperate of a situation to get out of
how does that feel to you do you feel
like you can do this
um I I think I can it's just that when I
look at the numbers it would be like
um if I even paid if I paid like 1300 in
my student loans even that would take 30
years if I pay 1200 which is what my
mortgage is that's 30 years and and so I
can pay 1500 on my mortgage and be done
in 15 years so I was planning on doing
that but then it's like you have to work
you know because they'll speed and all
that but if you do that it's like you
become a workaholic and then your kids
are like you know where were we you paid
off gazelle intensity is meant for a few
years it's not meant for decades at a
time and so uh number one we're gonna
send you Financial Peace University as
well as every dollar that's our Proven
Plan nine lessons the budget the full
kit and caboodle go through that but I
would not pay off the mortgage before
the student loans you can't bankrupt on
the student loans you can get rid of a
mortgage by selling your house one day
you can't get rid of Sallie Mae and so
I'm attacking that first save the house
for baby step six and let's send them
from paycheck to purpose because I think
you need a bigger shovel let's get that
income up so you can pay this off
quicker
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis this
hour open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
let's go to the phones Tom joins us in
Sacramento Tom welcome to the show
thank you George and Christina
um I just got a question more in our
late 60s uh we were behind in our
retirement savings well I have about a
hundred thousand in Deferred Comp and uh
retirement accounts and wondering if it
makes sense to take advantage of the
catch-up Provisions in my deferred comp
to exceed the 15 for the next three
years before retirement
um at the expense of maybe not paying
off the house quite before we get to
retirement so if you let's say you
invested 15 and then did everything else
onto the mortgage would you pay that off
by retirement
um it'd be pretty close
okay so it's kind of a either way you'd
have you're looking at the same numbers
how much do you have left on the house
about a hundred
and you said you have a hundred total
across all retirement accounts
currently yes what's your income right
now
um
about 180 awesome are you both working
yes okay and how how long do you see
yourselves working for you said you're
in your late 60s
do you see this going as long as it
takes
two or three more years okay and I and I
should say that the you know that we're
committed to selling the house when we
retire so and downsizing
yeah how much is the house worth
oh probably close to half a million
dollars I'm in California okay and then
outside of your 15 how much do you have
extra to either throw at the mortgage or
at retirement
um probably another another uh 10
percent
okay
would you be able to hit all of the
contribution limits for the catch-up if
you did that
yes my contribution limit for different
Compass 45
000 and I could hit that
so when you move when you move from the
half million dollar house where do you
plan on going after that as you downsize
are you going to stay in the same town
what's that move going to look like
no we plan to move near our children and
they're in a lower cost state so there'd
be a sizable amount of equity left over
so the goal would be to pay cash for
something really reasonable when you
guys sell
oh definitely okay because even
investing this money and doing the
ketchup contributions it's not going to
create you know a million dollars in the
next few years
and so no it either way it's not going
to move the needle significantly but uh
if I'm in your shoes I probably would
focus on those catch-up contributions
for now since you're gonna sell the
house as soon as you guys retire and so
you're you're not going to have a fixed
expense of the mortgage either way long
term in retirement
all right okay well that's how we have
been viewing it but
um we've been listening and it seems
like the
the ketchup isn't quite as important for
some but
we want to get get some input on I'd
appreciate that yeah and let me ask you
this are you guys working with a
financial advisor right now
yes okay and what is their take on your
situation
um that there's no wrong decision in
this regard that you know it's two good
choices but uh leaning towards
maximizing the Deferred Comp because the
tax benefit it saves us about six
thousand dollars a year in the state
federal taxes well it sounds like it
would give you guys a little hope for a
some dignity in retirement as well
well between our tensions and other
things we're we're going to be fine in
cash flow there but uh just you know
want to make the best decision possible
absolutely well thanks for the call Tom
appreciate it that's a tough situation
when you wake up and go we didn't do a
good enough job saving and we have to
really cram all this in within a few
years the good news is you have a
fantastic income making 180 if you can
live off a very small portion of that
and throw the rest at the mortgage and
into retirement for the next few years
that'll put you in much better shape
thanks for the call yeah there's a
beauty in kind of having that slightly
shorter timeline of like if you can see
that end goal if we're moving in two to
three years it's like let's just go all
in and be super intense in this season
work as hard as we can to catch up and
then in three years we're going to have
this beautiful retirement situation but
I'm proud of you all for really leaning
in right now and going okay we're gonna
go we're gonna go intense yes I'm proud
of for not bearing your head in the sand
and going well we'll just figure it out
when we get there we're just gonna keep
on living how we've been living love it
all right let's go to Courtney in Canton
Ohio Courtney welcome to the show
thank you guys how are you guys doing
doing so good how can we help
uh I've been wanting to start the baby
steps for quite funny now
honestly the only thing has been keeping
me from doing that is my partner
um it hasn't been the same partner the
whole time uh but now the boyfriend that
I have we live together and I've been
trying to get him on board with the baby
steps we're
shooting I think we have just a few
episodes left of FPU to watch
um but he doesn't really seem to be very
motivated to do anything about it uh
how's he doing financially
um I mean he has a steady income he
I think he has that thousand dollar
savings I haven't actually seen it so I
don't know but uh does this boyfriend
seem like long-term potential
what's that does this boyfriend seem
like long-term potential
I think so yeah okay you said it was a
different partner when you started
um what happened with that situation was
it the money that ended that
relationship or how did that transition
happen no yeah and did it due to uh him
getting kind of controlling and I said I
wasn't gonna do it how old are you two
uh I am 26 he is 32. okay
and you're saying you you're over
halfway through FPU and he hasn't really
changed his tune he's just kind of like
going through the motions to appease you
at this point
pretty much hmm
one of these conversations look like
when you kind of challenge him and
you're like hey I really want to go all
in what's his response
he said yeah I'd like to do it and then
when we go to have like a like a budget
meeting or like a dream meeting or
anything of A Sort uh he doesn't
anything that I ask them further than
that is I don't know
now you guys haven't combined any
finances correct
correct okay I would continue on the
baby steps on your own and I think the
long-term play is having the hard
conversations going uh I'm not breaking
up with you because of FPU but if we
don't align on really foundational money
values I don't see this going anywhere
because it doesn't sound like he has a
lot of vision for his life truthfully
yeah and that to me scares me more than
any kind of financial situation
because you sound like you've got goals
in life you have a vision for your life
you want to be somewhere five years from
now ten years from now that you're not
right now and he's fine just coasting
along
yes that's what worries me
so I'm not telling you to make any
decisions here but I think you need to
light a little fire and go this is more
serious than you think I'm not just
doing this to go hey will you go through
fbu with me I want to know are you on
board for having a vision for your life
and for our life together because if he
doesn't have a vision for his life he
ain't got one for you alls you
understand yeah
well that's the beautiful part about
dating is you're not tied to him long
term we talk to a lot of spouses who are
having these conversations where the
wife is like I can't get my husband on
board and she's frustrated and that's a
different conversation than when you're
just dating I mean that's part of dating
is figuring out you know what what
what's their motivation level what's the
future going to look like with this
person because if this is already
happening now in your dating
relationship then it's probably not
going to get better in marriage so we're
gonna get better when you combine the
finances and now he's got a whole
another opinion about what to do with
our money
yeah but I do love the idea of you going
ahead and setting the example because
you are dating and it is your money and
you shouldn't combine finances yet so go
ahead and leave the charge and hopefully
it'll motivate him but if not
I mean that's a pretty significant sign
yeah you you be your own gazelle and you
be the Thoroughbred and if the donkey
can't keep up that's on him you know
what I mean and so you got to live your
life don't wait on no man to get ahead
financially and achieve your goals and
on the way you might meet someone else
that does have those values and I'm not
saying he's not the one maybe he changes
his tune I hope he's listening to this
going dang Courtney's a special girl I
got to get my my game together because
I'm about to ruin this thing so best of
luck to you Courtney thanks for going
through Financial Peace University this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Ramsay show
appreciate you all listening if you're a
new listener with us and you want a
deeper dive into the Ramsey baby steps
and all the stuff we talk about on the
show you just want some direction
because you're new around here you can
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we're going to
help you figure out the best next step
for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today you just
answer a few simple questions and we'll
help you that's ramseysolutions.com
click on get started well with debt
payments and now inflation's stealing
more and more of your paycheck we know a
lot of you feel like you're drowning and
you're scared to death that you won't
have enough to take care of your family
but you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress and if you want things to
change you have to have your I've had it
moment and decide to try some new things
with your money and that means it's time
to try Financial Peace University this
is our nine lesson course that will
teach you how to beat debt and build
wealth it's everything you wish you
learned about how to handle money that
they didn't teach you at school
nearly 10 million people have now taken
FPU and they'll tell you they don't
worry about money like they used to they
are in control and you can be too so
decide that you are done stressing about
money and take control start Financial
Peace University today at
ramsaysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU Andrew joins us up next in Rockford
Illinois Andrew welcome to the show
are you with us Andrew hey there you are
I'm here what's going on
well me and my wife we're about 40 and
41 years old and we're driving by a
local community college today
and we have uh our kids esa's are going
to be about 40 and 40 40 and 50 000 for
each of them when they uh graduate high
school
and we're paying 14 to 1500 a month for
our house so it'll be paid off at almost
exactly that same time when they
graduate awesome nice
and we have also two hundred thousand
dollars in our retirement accounts right
now
and we're wondering what we should do
with those esa's if they go to the
community colleges and live at home to
go to a nearby in-state University
okay do you know what it's going to cost
for the community colleges
the Community College we are looking it
up as we're driving by and it's uh
for anything if they live at home which
will be which would cost way more than
the tuitions right now that's the they
would cost uh for each of them it would
be less than ten thousand dollars a year
okay that's great so you're on track to
have it paid for based on the current
rates when are they going to Community
College when would that be
they'll be my daughter who's 11 that
would be around 2030. Okay so we've got
plenty of time here
which means we don't know what it's
going to cost
well there's also the possibility that
they're going to go to Community College
then want to transfer to a four-year
School
that's what we're thinking they probably
will want to do we'll go two and two
yeah and then in that case then forty
thousand and fifty thousand could be
used up pretty quickly with the current
rates for four-year institutions plus
even beyond that they may want to get
additional education get a master's
degree get a certification and they'll
have other expenses like books and
laptops there's tons of qualified
expenses you can use that money for as
well
yeah not to mention further education
like a master's degree further schooling
different courses depending on what they
actually end up doing with their career
okay
yeah so I mean well then we would have
enough do you think the additional like
14 to 15 hundred dollars a month would
be enough to like pay for that
additional stuff to cash flow college is
that what you're asking
the cash flow after after using up the
esa because you'd have no mortgage
you're saying
we would after like we would after by
the time my daughter gets into college
we would have no more mortgage left over
and so if there was any extra money you
needed you could cash flow that because
you don't have a mortgage payment and
that's a great goal to have say hey we
want the mortgage paid off by the time
these kids go to college so that we can
continue to help and by the way they can
still work part-time they can still get
scholarships and you can withdraw funds
from the esa against those scholarships
uh with no penalty well if anything I
would encourage them to just be
strategic with their finances regardless
because you know if they don't end up
needing to use the money from the esa
because they won scholarships instead
that's even better yet so I wouldn't
stress out about it I think the 40 and
50 could easily be used if they get a
four-year degree but also if they
continue on further they're you know
you'll have the money that you could
potentially cash flow plus there are
other ways to pay for college
this is a great problem to have Andrew
that's all we're saying
you guys have done such a great job how
old are you two
uh I'm 41 and she's 40. awesome and
what's the household income
uh it's about a hundred thousand a year
fantastic and so over the next seven
years my guess is your income goes up
and you're going to pay off the house
and so this is not something I would
lose sleep over you guys are so far
ahead of the game to already have fit 40
50 Grand in there uh By the time they're
11 years old
and you think our 200 000 a year or 200
000 in our retirement accounts will be
enough to
if you continue investing at 15 I mean
you you do the investing calculator
online and go all right 200 Grand if I
continue investing 15 20 years from now
when we're 60 we're going to have a few
million bucks in the bank with a decent
rate of return
did say you're you're currently
investing 15 correct
uh not quite that much I think it's
lower probably towards eight or nine I
would bump that up today
and if that means we put Less in college
that's totally fine the A1 is baby step
four it's in that spot for a reason it
comes before saving for college we've
got to get the mask on first just like
we do on the plane
I don't want your kids to have to take
care of you because you were investing
eight percent and they were going well
thanks for sending me to college debt
free dad and now you have to live with
us right
so that's the goal all right
you guys are doing a great job though I
love hearing a parent that's 41 42 their
kids are young and they're saving
aggressively and having these questions
that is that is awesome for all the
parents that are listening who you know
their kids are going to go to college
and they're feeling like this is 15
years away I don't even need to think
about it let this be your wake-up call
be like Andrew and start thinking about
it now if you have if you're out of debt
if you're investing for retirement start
thinking about it now because that's
part of the reason why we have the
student loan crisis is there was not a
lot of conversations like that early on
a lot of kids are going to college with
no no insight into their financial
situation how many works the Mom and Dad
aren't going to pay for it that Mom and
Dad don't have the money these
conversations need to happen early and
parents if you can start saving early
that's just going to really help these
conversations well so many parents have
their own baggage and shame financially
and so they feel weird talking to their
kids about how they're broke and how
they can't pay for college but the
biggest blessing you can be is to tell
your kids we don't have money for
college and I want to help figure out a
way for you to still go debt free yeah
that's my story my mom could not afford
to pay to pay my college education but
she sat me down my freshman year of high
school and was super honest with me and
was just like Christina you're gonna be
on your own financially once you
graduate from high school so start
thinking about how you're going to pay
for college now and she told me about
this concept called scholarships and I
thought that sounded so exciting I was
like wait what if I start working now
then I could have all of this thousands
of dollars in free money to go to
college that sounds incredible and so I
just got obsessed with the idea of
scholarships I read every book I could
find I started interviewing alumni from
my high school who'd won scholarships
and I just went all in I built up my
resume I did a ton of volunteer work and
then my senior year of high school I
treated the scholarship application
process like a part-time job I just
applied like crazy and thank God it paid
off I was able to win over a half a
million dollars in scholarships and go
to school at Vanderbilt University which
is I learned last night I looked at
their website it is eighty four thousand
dollars a year right now I know crazy
but I was able to go to Vanderbilt
completely debt free and then get a
masters totally debt free all thanks to
my mom being willing to have the courage
to have a hard conversation and what she
couldn't give me in money she gave me
and motivation in that hard conversation
to be able to go I'm going to give you
insight into what your future is going
to look like and if you're willing to
work hard now and push through you can
go to school debt free I remember when I
hosted our personal finance curriculum
for high school and I was interviewing
these kids going Hey so uh what are you
studying why are you studying that what
do you want to do with that what kind of
job are you going to get what kind of
money you think that job's gonna make it
was like at a police interrogation some
kids ran out crying Christina and I
realized I'm the first one to ask him
these questions the parents aren't doing
it I shouldn't be America's Dad okay
Step Up parents have the hard
conversations now instead of causing
heartbreak and debt down the line go
check out borrowed future if you want to
sit down with your kid and have these
conversations and have it be a natural
fun encounter there you go yup that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to Christina Ellis my
co-host all the folks in the booth and
you America thanks for tuning in we'll
be back real soon
hey George Campbell here if you love the
show and you want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we've got a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you helpful
articles and tips on following the
Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving in storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm your host George
Campbell Join This Hour by Christina
Ellis and we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money if it's
uncomfortable if you're scared hey we'll
change your name we'll change the
information we just want to make sure
that you get the help you need to take
the right next step with your money
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Teresa's up first in Atlantic City
New Jersey Teresa welcome to the show
so or a family of six and we're
relocating due to a promotion and just
wanting to be close to family and while
we're selling our home we are now
renting from our family with low
payments but it's in an area that has
some gun violence and Drug you know
drugs close by
um now we can use what we earn from
selling our house to pay off student
debt and medical debt or we can put a
large down payment on a new house that
would be in a much better area
um so but we would still be paying about
in that house we would still be paying
about 30 to 35 percent uh depending on
the interest rate once we purchase okay
of our yeah so this house that you're
renting you guys you guys you guys moved
already or you're going to move we have
we have
you know we have lots of boxes unpacked
because we're ready to move again but
yes we are here uh we're here and what
is what is the rental cost what are you
paying per month
800.
and what's the new take-home pay with
the promotion household
um it's well right now 124
000 a year and that's take home
sorry
that's a gross yeah so I'm not sure what
that would be you know if you weren't
renting from family what's the average
rent in the area for a similar house not
not in a rough area
um probably probably over 2 000 I would
guess or just about just around there
I'm not I'm not too sure because we just
you know we just kind of moved back here
so but I would think around you know 2
000. okay so then you mentioned debt in
that the the money that you had from the
home sale could pay off that debt how
much debt is that
uh so we have about 16
000 in student loans and then I'm not
sure about medical but maybe you know
maybe five or
announce everything
that's every yes that's everything and
what was the what was the equity from
the sale of the home
a little over a hundred
so is that how much is kind of sitting
in the bank right now
it's not here yet so we still haven't
closed we close on the 13th of March
okay so a month from now ish you'll have
a 100K in the bank how much money do you
guys have right now aside from that
uh we just finished paying off all our
credit cards so we have very little in
the bank because we tried to uh pay
everything off so we could
um just be in a better place so you know
we don't have much maybe I I don't even
know it's not it's not much okay chump
change we'll call it your thousand
dollar starter emergency fund yeah does
that work okay yeah
you're renting this house from which
which means
my father-in-law
okay and he's had this house for a while
has he had a lot of problems with
tenants in that area
uh so he he was living here
um and he's you know he's a pretty low
maintenance guy and he doesn't it's not
like you know he comes home and
um it's not the same it's not
functioning the same as with me with
four kids you know so of course he's not
going outside and letting kids play
around outside
um you know he's kind of past that in
his year so can you guys get out of this
rental at any time
yes okay well here's what I'm doing if
I'm in your shoes as soon as that check
clears in that bank I am paying off all
my debt and that leaves you with what
forty thousand dollars in the bank
yes and with that forty thousand dollars
we're gonna set aside a big portion of
that for your emergency fund which I
imagine for a family of your size if we
set aside three to six months of
expenses it's going to be somewhere in
the ballpark of twenty thousand dollars
okay and I would be moving somewhere
else because you have a great income I
mean let's say an eight thousand dollar
take-home pay and you said you could
rent for two thousand
right yeah that's 25 which is exactly in
our parameters to where you still have
enough money to invest and live your
life and save for vacations and with the
extra money I'd be putting it towards a
down payment we should already have a
you know twenty thousand dollar Head
Start
okay so then we would miss out on like
this dream house that that offers a lot
so that and that's what's the Dreamhouse
the Dreamhouse it's you know in the
woods uh has acreage
um you know a greenhouse a pool
fireplace you know room for us to grow
room to put an in-law suite eventually
for our parents so it's it's kind of the
dreams
uh it's a 325. Well Teresa you said that
it would take 30 to 35 percent of your
take-home pay a dream house is not a
house that you can't afford and at 35
percent of your take-home pay that
that's not a dream that's gonna be real
stressful
and I think you know it that sign says
you know it you guys aren't that far
from this I mean if you're making that
income and you had no payments in the
world you could save up that down
payment pretty fast you got 20 000 in
emergency fund 20 000 head start on the
down payment how long would it take for
you guys to get back to your down
payment goal two years Max maybe a year
and a half
yeah it's we would just miss out on that
house yeah it would yeah when did you
find out about this house
we found out it was uh through
the church
he's leading you know he wants to sell
to us
um so it's so you found out a few months
ago
yeah like a month here's the point
people have dreams that are like when I
was a little girl I dreamed of being a
princess you just found out this house
exists there's going to be other houses
that you go this is my new dream house
because this one has the it has the
clawfoot tub I've always wanted the
clawfoot tub and so a lot of this is
just the emotional like I would just be
so nice to have that wonderful home
instead of renting well and when you're
living in the ghetto also seeing any
house that doesn't have people shooting
guns nearby right now surviving like a
dream survival is a great dream right
now
yeah you'll get there and you will love
the next house you're in and when you
step foot in that you're gonna do it
with such Financial Peace because the
payment isn't 35 or 40 of your take-home
pay and you are going to pay it off
early and be able to retire when you
want that to me is the bigger dream is
freedom let me throw out a quick a quick
question so this is a family friend that
has this house could you and he wants to
sell to you could you ask him if you
could rent it for a few years
like what would the cost be to rent from
him we are not he is not allowed to rent
in that area so it's not it's an area
that you cannot rent
um you know it's you're there you're
there to live there interesting what is
like the forest the HOA how does this
work it is it's like protected grounds
it's nearby yes are you renting in Fern
Gully I gotta know this sounds amazing
okay
well Teresa I appreciate the question
you guys are in a great spot I know it
stinks to be patient and save more but
when you pay off this debt and you free
up that income and you've got this big
family that you can now focus on instead
of worrying about the next paycheck to
cover that big mortgage for the dream
home that is now not the dream
[Music]
you're gonna be breathing easy so take
your time be patient hopefully you take
the advice that's what I would do if I
was in your shoes yeah that's great
thanks for the call
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis let's face it guys taxes are
confusing and if you buy what some tax
services out there say you might think
you'll never get a grasp on taxes and
shouldn't even try but we think you're
smarter than that and you deserve the
truth so here's today's tax tip you
ready you can cut out a lot of your tax
stress just by taking a few minutes to
get organized so if you haven't already
collect all those tax documents and put
them in one place that way you can see
if anything's missing all of your forms
should have been mailed or sent to you
electronically back in January forms for
your income your Investments your
mortgage things like that and if you're
missing something get in touch with
those folks now so you're not stuck when
you go to file
we've got free tax prep checklists at
ramsaysolutions.com to help you keep
track of your forms and records and once
you've got them all together and you're
comfortable using tax software Ramsay
smart tax will walk you through the
steps to file your federal return for
just 19.95 or if your situation is
complex we can connect you with a Ramsay
trusted tax Pro like one of our endorsed
local providers go to
ramseysolutions.com tax to get our free
tax prep checklist and work with a
service that's on your side that's
ramseysolutions.com tax
all right Christina you did no spend
January and the people want to keep it
going so now we have Frugal February
what is going on here yep we're we're
going into Frugal February a lot of
people who saw the no spin content in
January weren't quite ready to do it
themselves but they wanted to go into
February and so a lot of people are
doing a no spend month this month and
then other people who did no spend just
felt so on fire it's addictive it really
is they're like let's keep going let's
keep changing our lifestyle like we want
to be more frugal we want to reach our
money goals so I'm like let's go I love
it because for our family we've got you
know some aggressive goals this year
we're baby step six we want to have a
paid off house so we are like let's go
let's cut down as much as possible so we
can just tackle it so I'm all on board
with Frugal February and I've been
looking for different Frugal things to
share I've been asking people on
Instagram you know what are you focused
on right now how are you saving money
and I came across this really
interesting concept it's called the buy
nothing group and it's basically a local
Community where you give things away for
free and you get them for free and the
goal is pretty much to fight consumerism
and promote the idea of sharing like the
whole old adage the the one man's trash
is another man's treasure it's pretty
cool because it's like we live in this
Society now where it's so easy to just
one click order on Amazon and just buy
the thing that you need in that instant
and it's like do we really need to
purchase that do we all need things that
are new do we all need things right in
that moment so these groups the idea
behind it is that you give things away
and you get things and we share and and
just really help each other save money
in that way so I actually jumped online
and joined one of these groups last week
and it's pretty interesting you had to
type in like the nearest major
intersection to make sure that you
actually lived in the local community
and you could only Join one group so you
couldn't join like 12 groups and
prevents like the scammers and the
people trying to game the system right
and the idea is to create connection
between neighbors so it also has that
benefit of you know giving to people in
your local area and you have to give
freely so it's giving with no strings
this is just like peer-to-peer Goodwill
right instead of going a Goodwill you
just leave it on your porch for someone
else there you go saves you a trip well
that's what I was kind of thinking I'm
like I've been doing this pretty much my
entire adult life but it's pretty cool
to see people doing it like an official
capacity so I've shared the you know the
dining room table that we use right now
currently I've had for about 10 years
and I got it right after college from a
lady who lived in a really wealthy
neighborhood and she just didn't want to
bother to move her table and so she said
if you'll come and pick it up I'll give
it to you for free it was a 1400 table
wow perfect condition see I would want
to join the Facebook groups in the
wealthy neighborhoods where these people
are just giving really nice stuff away
right exactly and so it's pretty cool to
to see that like and the thing is is
it's it's not just on Facebook you can
do this on Marketplace you can do us on
different apps I saw an app earlier
called free alerts where it alerts
people who are giving it alerts people
about things that are being given for
free in their area so I'm like hey hey
you know what a lot of people don't want
to move their Furniture a lot of people
don't want to take the time to you know
move or haul something and it's like if
you're willing to do it you may be able
to get something or negotiate and haggle
with someone over five bucks because
they want to deal on it it just it's
going to be gone today if you just leave
it for free yeah exactly and I think
that a lot of people naturally want to
do this so in our old neighborhood there
was a community Facebook page and it was
fun to see people just posting things up
for free we actually got a 400 Playset
for free and then when we moved we
passed it on to another neighbor so I
just really want to challenge people
forward to pay it forward but also just
think before you just go out and buy
something think through you know is
there a way to potentially share this
and get it for free just like change
your mindset from the instant buys to
more of a community and you may be able
to do this in your church in your
neighborhood maybe you join a local buy
now group or Not by now
nothing group opposite of buy now but
change your mindset around that that's
one of the greatest things with
frugality I think a lot lot of our
grandparents did this naturally right
like we're Millennials and we're sitting
there going we came up with a group it's
an official title we're so clever but
this is something
but our generation has Amazon we have
all these one-click ordering Solutions
where we just buy so quickly but stop
and think you know how can we share more
as a community so that we're not
constantly just spending money that's
not necessary this is like take a penny
leave a penny for the modern world I
mean it goes you know you were short
you're like oh they're perfect there's a
little little thing of pennies right
there I don't have to come up with the
extra change does it make you less angry
than the the Starbucks like Pay It
Forward movement yes and now you know
there's buy now pay later I like this
version It's buy nothing pay never there
we go that's what we all share we all
share I love it well thanks for sharing
Christina appreciate that and good luck
to all of you on the no spend challenge
you're crushing let's go all right David
is calling from New Mexico let's see
what he has to say David welcome to the
show
hey thank you George good to be here
absolutely how can we help
well I'm thinking about retiring in a
few months and I've got a couple of IRAs
that are just sitting around doing
nothing and I'd like to find a way to
convert them into something that will
produce some income I'm a little afraid
of income annuities and I'm wondering if
there's some other product out there
that I don't know about now when you say
generate income what are what's invested
inside of this high in these IRAs
uh about 470 000. and what are they
invested in
um American Century Vanguard
um principle and you're saying it's not
generating income
uh they make a modest interest so what's
the rate of return that you've been
seeing obviously this year has been a
weird one
last couple of years have been weird
um I'm not sure
you're breaking up on this table digits
low single digits um low still digits
though I wonder if you're not invested
aggressively enough
I'm not sure
we'll see something maybe around six
percent seven percent okay
well I wouldn't jump into any kind of
annuities I don't like these contracts
with insurance companies that promise
payments I I would leave it aggressively
invested and then decide how much of
that you need to peel off of that do you
need this income in retirement how soon
will you need it
seriously I have a
investment accounts and all this all
pension what other adult life or Social
Security what other retirement savings
do you have
um
I have about 130 in just plain old
savings I've got a brokerage of account
that generates about 40 000 a year in
dividends
and I'll be applying for Social Security
when I'm 62 which is only a couple years
away
yeah so the goal would be not to need
the IRA funds right now and if you want
to you know obviously the the goal in
retirement is to minimize taxes and so
are you working with a financial advisor
right now to walk through what a
strategy looks like with all the
different buckets you have
not yet that's the next thing to do I
think I have that service available
through Merrill Lynch okay and you can
always get in touch with one of our
smartvester pros at ramseysolutions.com
but that's where I would be right now as
I'm getting close to retirement now is
it's crucial to be working with someone
who can look at this from a 30 000 foot
view go all right here's what we're
going to do we're going to utilize this
bucket first with your brokerage account
and we're not not going to touch the
IRAs until this point and then we're
going to use your cash savings over here
if in case there's a really down year
and you don't want to sell the shares at
a loss and so they can walk you through
all the nuanced strategies when it comes
to that but you've done a great job man
uh what's your income
[Music]
um 90 for my employment and then another
40 from the dividend awesome dude you
are on the path I would want to move
your Investments to something that's
producing uh better than six or seven
percent on average but I wouldn't pull
it out and put it into any kind of
annuity so get in touch with a
smartvester pro ramseysolutions.com get
a professional opinion on that but man
you are in so much better shape than
almost every single American way to go
proud of you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
Ramsey personality George Campbell
joined by Christina Ellis and the phones
are open at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Rhonda joins us up
next in Tampa Rhonda welcome to the show
hi there how are you guys doing doing so
great how are you is doing well thank
you
um thanks for taking my call I just
wanted to kind of call in as my husband
and I are trying to get better at just
managing our spending as we're wanting
to buy a house and kind of Super Save
um within the next year or so
um and my question kind of Lies around
credit cards so we both currently have
credit cards that we do not use with
zero balance and we're wondering if it
was best to kind of just cancel the
cards or if we should keep them open as
they're both kind of our longest line of
credit and was purchasing a house as
credit scores are kind of a big thing so
we just kind of wanted a advice on how
we should do that and kind of just
manage our money easier cool so do you
guys have any debt currently
we do not awesome and you have the fully
funded emergency fund where are you guys
at with that
yes we do have a emergency fund in our
savings currently yep great what is your
timeline for purchasing the house you
said soon about how many months or a
year
so our we live in an apartment right now
and our lease ends in July so
um we're kind of looking to maybe move
and maybe rent before we move out of our
kind of City see if we like where we're
moving we're looking at a city in
Georgia
um so there isn't kind of there isn't
really like a concrete timeline but
we're just wanting to kind of get in the
best case scenario for when we are ready
to buy a house love it so what is your
down payment goal
so our down payment goal is between 10
and 20
um we were looking at buying a house but
we weren't necessarily too crazy
comfortable
spending more than five percent so we
decided to kind of just wait it out
um so yeah we're definitely wanting to
put down as much as possible love it and
that's a great goal I mean 20 will help
you avoid private mortgage insurance as
you probably know and what's your
household income
so for the year we make about
180 together love it and so what if you
put a number to this goal that 10 to 20
what does it amount to
um I would say
let me think probably closer to between
30 and 50
000.
okay awesome and you'll get I mean you
that won't take you guys long at all
with your income with no debt so here's
here's what I'm doing in your shoes you
do not need the credit score to buy the
house and I say that because I did it
myself through the no score loan manual
underwriting process and our friends at
Churchill Mortgage do these all day and
let me tell you Rhonda I put out a video
the other day and I rocked the entire
internet in anger because they were
calling me a liar and they just couldn't
google it for themselves apparently and
so the truth is once you close all of
your accounts your credit score should
become indeterminable which means it's
not technically a zero there's that you
can't really get to zero it just
disappears off the face of the Earth
and that would cause you to have to go
through the manual underwriting process
which just means a real person looks at
Rhonda's financial situation and goes
okay they make 180k they have an
emergency fund they've got 20 down
they're doing a 15-year fixed yeah we'll
give you a mortgage with a great
interest rate by the way
mm-hmm and so there's no need to keep
the credit cards open and the sooner you
close them the sooner you can begin that
process of that credit score becoming
indeterminable which is great because
you guys are going to go rent for a year
while that happens and continue to save
the down payment well and that's what I
was going to highlight is there is that
period of time when your credit score is
going to indeterminable where it could
fluctuate it can fluctuate so yeah
canceling the cards as quickly as
possible so there is that leeway we sold
our house last year last May and still
had a mortgage on that house and so when
we sold it we went through the process
of it going to indeterminable and there
was that nerve-wracking seven months
where I'm like when's it gonna go when's
it gonna go I was literally asking Dave
I was like Dave it's not gone away yet
when is it going away
um so there is that period that little
limbo period while it's going away
um so yeah the sooner the better so that
you have that Runway before you're
really really aggressively searching for
a house
yeah awesome thank you for that that
definitely helps um and then maybe just
last
um any we're trying to do the no spend
February any crazy
tips to try and you know save as much as
possible and kind of budget our finances
better yes I love it I think getting
aggressive with your grocery budget is a
big thing
um we did no spend and then it's easy to
leave that grocery budget there and kind
of eating up your whole budget but we
went down to a hundred dollars a week
and going into the grocery store with a
meal plan with a list we even got online
and pre-shopped in advance where we were
like looking at all these website going
okay how much does this cost and doing
all the math to make sure that our total
would be under a hundred and it was a
fun challenge for us
um and then we had several people who
did like charts where they would have
the month laid out and then they would X
Out you know win days days that they did
really well so that if they did have a
day where they happened to not do the no
spin challenge where they fell off the
wagon they didn't then go oh well the
whole month was a fail like we didn't do
it it's like no it was one bad day but
you got to start again the next day
um but then we also just had a lot of
people who went all in and I think
that's one of the good things about
going all in is it's like when you take
all spending out all discretionary
spending out for a month it's like that
boundary is so it's so hard that it's
like actually easier than a lot of
people thought a lot of people I got a
ton of DMS where people are like I
thought that I could never do this I'm a
free spirit I'm a spender I didn't think
I could do this but having that strict
boundary where you're like this is just
one month and we're gonna go all in it's
like they were very surprised by the
results
yeah well awesome thank you that
definitely helps you I try to stick to a
meal plan and stick to the grocery list
and not buy all of those extra snacks
and things that look good in the moment
but don't necessarily fit within the
budget oh yeah and the other one you can
do you know I use every dollar and do a
budget audit where you literally go
through every single item and go could
we do better there do we need that could
we cut that for a month hey how can we
shave that down yeah let's get rid of
that and you start to really see the
margin because it'll show you at the top
of your every dollar budget as you
change those numbers out so if you can
figure out a way to save 200 and then
make 200 by selling stuff or doing a
side hustle that's a 400 spread every
single month that's five grand a year
and so all of a sudden you get a little
pep in your step when you start to see
the numbers and what it does for your
budget yeah the momentum is amazing and
also get in community if you have
anybody else who wants to do it with you
that is really helpful having that extra
level of accountability is amazing
especially if it's like neighbors who
might see you at the grocery store if
you end up snacking and walking out with
a he car I know that was big for me
knowing that I was doing it with the
Instagram Community I was like if I go
over budget somebody will probably see
me but just knowing that there were
other people in the ring with me where
it's like you know my church or my
friends are doing it and we're all in
this together and we all want to win
together that's just also nice to have
that accountability to push you
um
great great spot and I love the
conversation about manual underwriting
because it feels like it no one
understands that it's real and they
think well if you just have an FHA loan
or a VA loan I've heard about that but
this is a conventional loan we're
talking about and if you have 12 months
of rental history of consistent on-time
payments and then you have another
source of non-traditional credit things
like your cell phone bills your
insurance bills all of that counts
towards you qualifying for this
conventional mortgage especially when
you follow our plan and you have an
emergency fund and you have the a great
income that can cover your payment
because you're doing the 25 or lower and
the 15-year conventional we ran the
numbers with one of my buddies at
Churchill you get the same exact
interest rate if you do a 15-year
conventional fixed rate mortgage with at
least 10 percent down as someone who has
a great or excellent credit score I
would have just as good of an interest
rate that is powerful because that's
another comment I got well your interest
rate is going to be 47 on that mortgage
this guy's an idiot and I'm just going I
just told you I did it like lies lies
and they're just frustrated because they
want to be homeowners they don't think
it's possible they think they have to
play the games of the system and play
the credit score games that ends up
keeping them in debt longer and keeps
them further away from home ownership so
get in touch with our friends at
Churchill if you want to know about this
process
this is for U.S residents only Canadians
I'm sorry for some sorry for some reason
they just don't allow manual
underwriting in Canada so uh I don't
know what it takes to move to the US I'm
sure it's difficult these days but it's
just life is better in America that's
all I can say ouch
sorry sorry not sorry
hey more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour
we've got a question of the day from
Kristen who was hanging out in our
Facebook group The Baby Steps
millionaires Community not just for
actual baby steps millionaires but if
you're an aspiring baby status
millionaires you're on that path uh be
sure to go join that Facebook group and
here's her question
I'm saving for college for children we
have an 18 year old that will be
starting College in January we will not
be on baby step five for a while but do
we save for her College even though she
will already be in college do we help
her pay for it or do we just leave that
to her I don't know what is the right
thing to do hmm well I'm a little
confused by the question because she's
saying they're saving for we're about to
start saving for college but they're not
on baby step 5 yet right so I'm assuming
they still have debt that's what it
sounds like they're probably in baby
steps one through three and they're
going hey she's gonna be in college do
we start safe do we just go ahead and
help her with that or do we just leave
that to her since we're not at a place
to do it yet well if you're still in
debt I'm gonna encourage you to to wait
and pay off your debt like you need to
focus on getting yourself out of the
hole there are other ways for her to pay
for her college education and y'all need
to start focusing on that debt and
getting yourselves prepared for
retirement and all the other you know
the first four baby steps now it's a
little challenging because she's already
18 and you said she starts in January so
she probably I'm assuming already has a
vision for where she wants to go I'm
hoping that Vision doesn't include a
fifty thousand dollar school that she
can't afford and that's where the
conversation is going to get interesting
because have you had these conversations
before or is this going to Blindside her
at this point has she thought all along
that Mom and Dad going to pay for my
college education and this is going to
be a hard conversation and if so I mean
that's okay there's a lot of parents in
that situation but I would just prepare
yourself for a difficult conversation a
level setting conversation and you may
even need to apologize and say we should
have had this conversation sooner I'm
really sorry I didn't do well with money
that's why we're in debt and we've got
to go back and you know clean up our
mess and with that we don't have money
to pay for your college and so you may
not be able to go to that four-year
private school that you've been dreaming
about we may need you to you may need to
go to Community College first for two
years you may need to go to a tuition
assistance program I mean there just may
need to be some adjustments
unfortunately just given this the where
you are in the process and it's a hard
conversation it is hard but you know I'm
proud of you for asking the question and
if you're willing to Pivot now there are
all sorts of options you know there's
obviously changing schools but if she's
a bright student perhaps she can get
scholarships perhaps you can Empower her
to figure out you know how she can
qualify maybe she can get a full ride to
a different school but I would
definitely you know put the onus on her
and try to empower her to figure out how
to pay for her education and of course
take student loans off the table because
we're in the student loan crisis right
now so many people didn't have this
conversation and they just let their
kids go into crazy amounts of debt so
that is not the option but it's probably
not going to be a super fun conversation
at this point yeah we need to do more
research and go what are the options can
you live at home for the first year and
go to that local Community College to
save money and maybe that puts a fire
under you guys to go we kind of get out
of debt in the next two years so that we
can help cash flow the other two for her
that's a huge goal for us we want to be
there for her and so yeah I think
encouragement coaching is really the
best best thing you can do for her right
now not sacrificing your own retirement
your own debt Freedom so that we can
help her go to college that's not the
goal right now yeah and I just think a
lot of Grace for both of you guys in
this conversation because you're in the
baby steps millionaire Community you're
working through the baby steps you're
doing the best you can so I know that
you're probably feeling shame right now
and frustration that you don't already
have the cash for it she's probably
gonna feel a little frustrated that
she's gonna have to figure out a way but
I'm proud of you both for all of you for
actually getting on the journey but with
all those feelings of Shame with all
those feelings of kind of being like uh
that's that that still needs to like the
conversation still needs to happen even
though it's a hard conversation even
though it's not the most fun
process right now be willing to do it
absolutely thanks for the question
Kristen all right let's go to the phones
Leslie is up next in Minneapolis Leslie
welcome to the show
hi um thank you for taking my call so
the reason for my call today was in my
senior year of high school I was working
a bunch of jobs I saved up a bunch of
money to buy my first car and to pay for
college I would say I saved about three
thousand dollars at the time and because
I was 17 a minor my mom was like the
owner of my account essentially so she
had access to it and she asked me to
borrow three thousand dollars and
because I've been watching Dave Ramsey
since I was like 16 I knew that was a
dumb idea so I said no but because she
had access to my account she went ahead
and took that money out anyways and then
a couple months later she never paid me
back a couple months later she went to a
police auction and bought a unregistered
car that failed the Minnesota safety
exam twice so it was unsafe to drive and
then she forced me to spend another 2
000 on repairing this car because like I
said it wasn't drivable so I'm just kind
of in a rut right now like I don't know
what to do about my next vehicle how old
are you
um I'm 18 years old so this was a year
ago was this this the past 12 months
this was a year ago and even though the
car was unsafe to drive I was still
driving it almost actually got an
accident so recently I just stopped
driving it so I don't drive right now
what is the current relationship with
your mom
um so we try to maintain a good
relationship aside from like just the
financial aspect of this I would say I'm
really hurt on an emotional level yeah
that that you have every right to be
that's a lot so you said there was the
original 3000 and then you said she
forced you to do the additional 2000 how
did that happen
well she bought it without my consent
right like she she took um she bought
this card for fifteen hundred dollars
bought it without my consent
um never gave me my 3000 back and
because
um you know she had access to my account
she pulled another two thousand dollars
out of my account to fix this car so how
and also um sorry um I forgot to mention
she also suggested that I take out
student loans to buy a car and mind you
I'm on full academic scholarships right
now so I have no loans and she suggested
that I should take out student loans to
get a car
how have these conversations with your
mom gone you said you still have a a
decent relationship but you anybody in
your situation I just want to stop for a
second and validate would feel
emotionally hurt that is a very hurtful
thing but the money aside I'm just so
disappointed about the person who's
supposed to protect me would even do
this
where are you living now
um I live on campus okay I go to the
University of Minnesota are you working
uh yes I do and are your finances now
separated from your mom
like she as soon as I turn 18 on my 18th
birthday I didn't even have a party I
went to the bank get it girl well before
we even dive any further we'll make sure
you stay on the line after this call
we're gonna get you a copy of own your
past change your future by Dr John
deloney because you've got a lot to sort
through you've got the financial part
and that's just incredibly hurtful
you're grieving the loss of the finances
but really the loss of this relationship
because you can't trust mom anymore and
that's what every relationship is based
on
yeah what's worse is if I even bring up
like how disappointed I am she's like
well if it wasn't because of me you
wouldn't even have a car you're so
ungrateful I've done so much for you I
gave birth to you you don't even know
what I'm going through I really needed
that money that's what she must be going
through something does she have any
addictions does she have big spending
problems
she has a very bad spending problem and
um her and my dad are going through some
marital problems too so that doesn't
help well I would also so just to lay
the very Foundation you said you're at
college I would see if there's a mental
health office at your college where you
can see a counselor because right now
you're going through a lot of
manipulation there's a lot of turmoil
right now the relationship with your mom
is not healthy and you know that but
it's hard because it's your mom it's a
primal wound you feel that draw towards
your mom you want her in your life right
we all want to have those types of
relationships but this isn't healthy and
I think it will help you to have some
outside consistent consultation where
somebody can go you you are valid and
being mad about this like this is
hurtful but then also to help separate
this is hurtful this is your past but
how are we going to move forward in the
future how are you going to get rid of
those wounds and those hurts so that you
can move forward with your life in a
healthy way so Leslie how much money do
you have right now
um I have about four thousand dollars in
my savings account right now that she
does not have access okay good we're
gonna see how much we can get for your
current car it may be pennies and we're
gonna get you a safe car and if you can
borrow one for now ride around with
friends that's what I'm doing around
campus for now but what a sad situation
I'm so sorry for what you have gone
through you're gonna climb out of this
thing and it's gonna be a stupid tax and
it's not your fault but it's your
responsibility on what you do moving
forward thanks for the call that puts
this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books
Christina Ellis
Ellis episode and want to know more
about getting started on the Ramsay baby
steps go to ramsesolutions.com and click
on the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell hosting
this hour with my friend Christina Ellis
open phone's triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your mind and if
you're listening to the show I'm hoping
you enjoy the show and if you do enjoy
the show here's what I asked because the
show is free yet we're not going to do a
Telethon we're not asking for your money
here's what I ask and it's free if you
like the show consider subscribing
following leaving a review and sharing
with a friend it takes you a few seconds
to click another click hit the five star
say something nice and share it with a
friend who might enjoy this might
benefit from the financial device we are
Dolan out here on the show let's go to
the phones Ethan kicks it off in Orlando
Ethan welcome to the Ramsey show my
friend how you doing
hi I'm doing good what's going on uh
something I'm wondering about is my
roommate isn't quite able to make the
rent every month and I'm wondering how I
can get him on a budget and then uh if
at the end of the lease he's not able to
to pay back the money we've lent him
over time oh do I just write that off as
as stupid tax or or hope that he can end
up paying me back he's not able to or he
doesn't want to
I don't know he makes room for his
groceries and his other stuff that he
ends up being late every month on the
ramp what's his reaction like like are
you like buddies with this guy or is
this like a true like roommate we found
this guy on Craigslist
uh yeah the three of us we've all been
friends uh for several years since you
know early High School
when he when he can't pay like what what
does he say is he just constantly
bumming money off you guys is he
remorseful or do does he like slap in
his pockets like oh man yeah
yeah he seems a little sorry but he
Moore just lets us discover oh looks
like we got a late fee what okay well we
haven't paid on time okay why did that
happen who's this money getting paid too
who's the landlord
uh this like you know huge you know
renting company
well I think that's the next step if
this guy can't pay is they get to a
victim because he's not making rent and
you find a new roommate who can and you
have that hard conversation
okay because it seemed it felt more like
from their perspective the the company
that it's more like you know total bill
needs to be paid and they don't care who
pays it but you think you're saying it's
more like a can they split it into
different payments or do they need it
all as one giant lump sum and they go
hey you roommates you figure out who's
who's gonna actually write that check
we all have accounts on their website
but they just see what it is at the end
of the month it's just one tab that
we're all chipping into
I would talk to them and say Hey listen
we're on the lease two of us are paying
just fine this guy's not what are our
options here
because right now you're just enabling
him by allowing him to take this
interest-free loan every month I mean
how how far behind is he on rent
uh in total it's like fifteen hundred
dollars
he's never paid the electricity bill
what
how is he okay with this
because we've been patient with them but
you know after these few months you
don't be patient with idiots they'll
drag you down with them this guy's a
grifter yeah
how have these conversations gone like
have you had these real conversations
with him or you're just like hey dude
like we can't keep doing this
yeah what we've done is I've given them
like payment plans where you say all
right we're going to do this much this
month this much that month and I
projected out for him for the whole year
and he's like gee thanks and then
uh next month he didn't quite make it
it's like well what happened to the
payment plan he's like okay okay
even the fact that he says gee thanks
like his response to your generosity and
to you floating him this money is G
thanks is there's not respect there dude
I I'd have his mattress on the lawn and
change the locks and say you don't live
here until you pay rent
and that's not because I'm a bad friend
or whatever he's putting you guys in a
terrible Financial spot and now using
you
to enable his stupid Behavior
well I don't know that you can legally
put the mattress on the lawn listen I
don't know that you can legally not pay
rent for a year and make your friends
give you loans and put you on payment
plans even though you're not the
landlord well that's where I would
change it from a friendship relationship
where this is all one group of friends
paying rent and like George said I would
call the landlord and say okay this
dude's not paying we may need to evict
him we need to figure this out like we
need to know our options I'm gonna say
you've got one month to come up with
that 1500 bucks you owe and then you are
on time every single month in fact
you're early and if you're not you can't
live here anymore because we need
someone who pays reliably on time that
was the agreement when you signed that
lease are you willing to have this
conversation because part of it is like
George said to be enabling like this is
not a budget meeting this guy doesn't
want to pay
and he's not really being your friend
like the fact that he's putting you in
this financial situation and really
taking advantage of you is not a good
friendship
and if that's why I'm saying if you go
to the company and make them the bad guy
that will at least put some fuel on this
thing
yeah I can imagine that he doesn't quite
notice the gravity of it like if he
didn't have such nice friends he would
be evicted like you that would have
happened exactly but you know what
happens when you do it one month and the
next month it just becomes normal
and so he gets used to stupidity instead
of having to actually change his
behavior I mean this guy's working right
he's making money
yeah he works at like an oil change
place and if he can't afford to live
there he just needs to find a new place
to live it's not a because I'm a bad
friend you guys can still be friends
with him when he moves out in fact
you're probably better friends with him
when you're not part of his landlord
situation
yeah it's made things awkward
yeah what's your rent what's the cost
I total 24.50 a month and you guys split
that three weeks another like 100. yeah
well I pay a little bit more since I
have the master bedroom but yeah okay
so what's his share 700 bucks
uh no yeah he plays like 790 and then
another like you know 60 or whatever in
utilities and he's not paying
electricity for some reason
yeah he just hasn't done that yet when
does this lease end
at the very end of August
okay and are you planning to renew this
lease I hope I know the answer
no hey we definitely can't you know yeah
he needs to be calm
the back of my brain wanted me to you
know find a place that's two thousand
dollars a month with them but you know
when I asked them okay what can you
afford he's like I guess 700 and it's
like well what do you mean you guessed
that's you need a budget
I mean you're I'm happy to gift you
Total Money Makeover to gift to him I
don't think this guy is gonna crack the
cover of it to be honest
because he doesn't want to change
he's not coming to you for financial
advice he's coming to you for handouts
has he has he once said man I'm just my
paychecks are tight can you help me
figure this out has he once said that
no he's never had me sit down with him
I think that's very you never asked me
to mm-hmm
I think you need to channel your inner
George energy dude I'm getting
aggressive with him my little man
syndrome comes out in these situations
I'm just not putting up with that crap
your your life is too important your
financial future is too important to let
this goober stick around and put you in
a bind with this weird personal loan
situation where now you have to start
hassling him for the money going Where's
My Money where's my money I'll get it to
you next month bro
he's out you're also not his parent the
fact that you're like trying to talk to
him about money and he's like gee thanks
that's like something that like a child
would say to their mother like not two
grown adult friends
I'm fuming right now I'm sorry Ethan you
got to go through this find better
friends is A1 but next step let's get
this guy out of here
[Music]
you're listening to the Ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I'm George Campbell joined by
Christina Ellis this hour well Christina
I have been uh playing around with this
new tool called chat GPT it has taken
the World by storm it's a very fancy AI
tool where you can just give it some
prompts and it can spit out things and
all of its knowledge comes from 2021 and
previous and so it's not quite Google
but it's fascinating one of our
Engineers had some fun with this and
said give me a song about Dave Ramsey
and here's what the robots out there
decided would be a great song we're
gonna do this in a few parts Christina
we're not going to sing it because we
want to stay on air but give us the
first verse in chorus all right let's go
chat robot verse one he'll teach you how
to save your cash Homemaker money grow
he'll show you how to live below your
means and let it flow Dave Ramsey he's
the man with financial wisdom in his
hand he'll guide you through the ups and
downs on the road to financial soundness
off to a rocky start all right let's
continue to verse two he'll teach you
how to pay off debt and not to live in
fear he'll show you how to invest for a
future that is clear Dave Ramsey he's
the man with financial wisdom in his
hand he'll guide you through the ups and
downs on the road to financial soundness
he's got a plan for you and me to live a
life of financial Glee so listen to his
words of advice and you'll be living the
good life twice
back to the chorus Dave Ramsey he's the
man with financial wisdom in his hand
he'll guide you through the ups and
downs on the road to financial soundness
so take his advice and run and you'll
see the money come Dave Ramsey he's the
man with financial wisdom in his hand
wow well okay I think it's safe to say
that human songwriters have job security
yeah the robots have not yet figured out
how to replace true creative art and
truthfully they don't even know how to
rhyme yet I mean those were some pretty
rough Rhymes but it was better than I
thought it would be by a robot there
actually was money
the concepts are there if it wasn't a
song maybe like a haiku I would buy it
but Financial soundness I don't know
that anyone's ever used that term and
that didn't rhyme no it felt like just
like the Kidz Bop edition of Ramsay you
know you remember those commercials
growing up wow and financial Glee I
haven't heard that one either I kind of
like that too live a life of financial
Glee so here's the challenge for you all
listening out there if you want to add
music to this you want to sing it
the power is in your your hands so
here's what we want you to do we're
going to put these lyrics in the show
notes on podcasts in the description on
YouTube and if you so choose again on
your own volition to come up with some
music some Melody take some creative
artistic license here
you can email us ask ramsaysolutions.com
with your song submission and maybe
we'll feature it on the show it's a big
maybe it's a big maybe this was so bad I
don't know that I ever wanted Unearthed
ever again yeah I'm like the bar is not
super high y'all like I have a feeling
we've got some creative people out there
that can do quite a bit better than the
robot if you can polish this thing up
you might have a music career ahead of
you so ask ramesesolutions.com you can
check out the lyrics in the show
description podcast show notes send us
your final song you've made from these
somewhat okay lyrics
wow
have you used chat GPT yet I played with
it it's pretty fascinating it does a
decent job depending on what you feed
into it the prompts that you give it
it's kind of wild like it yeah some of
the prompts and some of the output I'm
like oh
like there's gonna be something if
there's a complex topic and you're like
hey explain to me this topic like I'm
five years old and make it fun and light
and it can do that
so we can you know we can talk about I
don't know 401ks or something there you
go so check it out while you can before
they start charging for it because you
know they're gonna monetize that thing
in no time
that's wild I wouldn't recommend taking
Financial advice from it yet I grew up
in the era of Ask Jeeves do you remember
Ask Jeeves I do it was like the original
Google
George that makes us sound old I know I
had a geocities website too my Myspace
that was my thing that's right editing
the HTML backgrounds oh I love it we
feel so old yeah that's that's a little
painful that hurts a little gen Z is
like what what is MySpace what's what's
that top eight oh my gosh I love it well
let's get to the phones here and Jason
is awaiting in Saint Louis Jason welcome
to the show
hi thanks for having me sure how can we
help
um so I'm recently
um getting a arm changing positions at
my current job
um well I'm not going to be offered
health insurance
and we've been we started Financial
Peace in January I mean we really just
kind of jumped off with it all you know
we knocked a lot of debt down I think
plus like 70 000 we paid off in the last
like month and a half whoo awesome
payments and you know getting rid of
some debt
um so I was just kind of curious on the
best way to go about getting health
insurance because my wife is
self-employed and doesn't obviously
qualify for it through her employment
um and I looked at the marketplace my
private insurance
and it's you know like anywhere from
like 900 to 1000 bucks a month
um we don't have any medical conditions
we don't take any prescriptions
um so I'll just kind of seems like a
waste you know spend that kind of money
but I just don't want like and we have a
six-year-old you know so I don't want
anything to happen and then yeah you
need help it's a non-negotiable that you
need health insurance it doesn't matter
how healthy you are today it's about the
what ifs in life and medical bills can
rack up to six seven figures very
quickly yeah and we don't want to we
don't wanna
you know decide our boat that we're
doing right now sure when you change job
positions did you know that it would be
an insurance change did you have
insurance before this new position what
what's kind of that look like yeah yeah
so I did know um but
um I'm trying to just let my wife get
her business growing
um
so we knew that we're gonna have to pay
out of pocket I didn't realize it was
going to be this much
um I talked with a broker and she
recommended like a short-term Insurance
it kind of covers like the catastrophic
stuff
I don't know if you guys were familiar
with those or yeah I mean there's things
like Cobra as well when you leave a job
there's kind of that gap insurance but
you need something long-term because
there's not your situation isn't
changing anytime soon as far as work and
employment and benefits we could so I'm
I'm waiting for a night shift to open up
what kind of work are you nurse a nurse
I'm a nurse and there's no health
insurance provided as a nurse
uh not as a PRN Solutions I pretty well
pick up shifts whenever they have
available like I work in a float pool
so I have like nine hospitals throughout
One hospital system that I flow between
so like I can pick up
at any of these places
um so like the work's not going to be an
issue you know finding it I just
have to pay more you know out of pocket
for my health insurance are there other
positions that would provide health
insurance
um well like I said this the position
I'm currently in is a very good
um paying job so I just really need to
wait until the night shift opens up so
that's going to be the trade-off is
because it's a better paying job you're
going to have to use some of that better
pay to cover the more expensive health
insurance through the marketplace
because it's not going to be subsidized
through your employer
yeah well the night shift
um provide you with insurance well like
if you do get that position
okay well so I'll be back to a full-time
position um and it'll work better like I
said with my wife's being able to build
her business more um and then we don't
have any help with our son like child
care
okay so this really is a temporary thing
and in the ideal scenario
yeah okay you know black I'm not going
to say in this long term that's why I
was looking at the short term
um have you connected with one of our
Ramsey elps endorsed local providers or
was this an outside agent
I was an outside agent just a local one
by me okay I'd get a second opinion if
you jump onto ramseysolutions.com click
on trusted Services then click on
insurance and then health insurance they
can help shop you uh all the types of
insurance you might need depending on
your situation depending on how long and
just know in the meantime you might have
to tighten up that budget and go this
stinks that we're paying you know a
thousand bucks a month right now but
we've got to get the right coverage
don't skimp on this in the short term
because it can lead to financial ruin if
you start skipping around on this
yeah
and but congrats on the new position
hope long term we can find you something
with good health benefits I mean it's
one of the main reasons people choose a
job is the benefits and especially
health insurance because it's an insane
situation uh here in America and a lot
of other countries so get that taken
care of ASAP never have a gap in health
insurance and connect with one of our
Ramsey elps at ramseysolutions.com they
can help independently shop all of the
different companies out there to get you
the best rate this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour
on the Ramsey Show we're here to help
you figure out the right next steps for
your money and sometimes we do that
through live events on the road and we
are so pumped to do that with our
Building Wealth live tour coming up
starting next week all of the Ramsey
personalities are going to be scattered
across these events and it's a proven
plan for your money that will work even
in this economy so you can catch us in
Indianapolis on February the 16th I'll
be there with Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz
and Jade warshaw February 23rd you can
go to Austin Texas to see Dave Ramsey
Ken Coleman Dr John deloney and Jade
warshaw then we're headed to Salt Lake
City on April 24th with Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz Christina Ellis and myself
and finally we'll end it in Anaheim
California on May 2nd with Dave Ken Dr
John and Christina tickets start at just
49 bucks and you can get a four pack
starting at 175. these seats are going
fast our last fall tour sold out so you
don't want to wait on this reserve your
seats now ramseysolutions.com slash
events is the place to go you ready to
hit the road Christina I am so excited
these events have been electric oh I've
heard such great things about them and
it feels like the the baby personalities
the new ones are finally spread their
wings
yes I love it we're gonna have a good
time join us for that all right let's go
to the phones Tim is in Virginia Beach
Tim welcome to the show
hey thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it yeah what's going on
so my wife and I have been stuck in baby
step two for what feels like forever and
I it seems like every time we start to
get some traction a big ticket item
kills our momentum uh like you know
something that's much more expensive
than just what the thousand dollar
emergency fund covers
um just in the last probably five years
we've had hvacs that have completely
died
um we've had uh we had a pipe burst in
our house and uh unfortunately
homeowners insurance wouldn't cover it
that costs us about four grand out of
pocket to take care of
um we have four vehicles my wife and I
and our two adult kids
um we are paying payments on my wife's
car but my mine and my two kids are
older model cars and just this week my
son's car was in the shop to the tune of
650 and my daughter's car was in the
shop to the tune of 750
ouch and just makes it feel like you
know we've actually we actually keep two
thousand dollars in our emergency fund
just because we so many times something
hits us that's a thousand dollars or
more and just wipes it out so we we've
started keeping two thousand in there
that seems to be a good number that can
we can take care of something right away
and not have a car parked for a couple
weeks waiting to make more money to
cover the expense but what would be your
advice because you know listening to all
the the teachings and the stuff you know
maybe they've been discussed on on your
shows but I I don't really hear people
talk about how to handle those big
expenses especially like when things go
wrong in the house and you're trying to
work the baby steps and it's like man it
just is like gut punch to have you know
some of these things happen and you just
don't really have the fund and you're
you're facing did we Finance or or what
do we do um
well how much debt do you have total
let's talk about baby step two and where
you're at what is your total debt
okay so our total debt we have uh about
twenty eight thousand dollars in credit
card debt we owe 15
000 to uh is left to pay on my wife's
car
we have a little over 40 000 of student
loan debt and we have our home uh we
have about 180 uh thousand to pay on our
home okay and what is your house we got
a long run we got a long road ahead of
us well what is your household income
oh well that actually is pretty good so
I make I bring home 90 000 a year and my
wife has just recently got into travel
nursing
um and so she's making uh she made 120
she makes about a little over 120 000 a
year oh my God so combined you're over
yes well this past year yeah so for 2022
yes
um we were right at about 180 000 on the
previous year was our gross income
how much how much debt have you paid off
thus far in the journey you said you've
been doing this for for 10 years how
um
uh well we pay well seeing this is we've
paid all cars and then we have had to
finance my wife's car and that's a whole
other story in itself
um we paid off uh several credit cards
um
uh what is her car worth today
I think the current Carfax on it is
about 15-5 and we I think we owe just
shy of 15 000 on it okay
well here's the good news with this new
found income this debt is gone this year
and there's nothing that's going to stop
you because what I'm hearing is okay we
had a 600 repair 400 repair that's not
enough to completely halt the debt
snowball when you're making 200 Grand
and so I think a lot of it is more
emotional than it is financially there's
a lot of other expenses and while my
wife and I are both on this plan that
you know I mean you know full disclosure
you know like like our daughter does not
work she's a she's a college student and
she goes away to college and that is
like you know we she she has we we give
her 800 a month to help cover things
while she's in college plus we pay for
you know we pay for everything while
she's in college so I know that that
could probably be argued as to why we do
that or not but it is what it is it's
her room and board paid for her meals
already through the school or what yeah
so she's got a scholar she's an athlete
so she's got a partial college athletic
scholarship and then she's got an
academic scholarship and the rest of it
is
um she's actually taken student loans
out for the remaining for the other part
of it
but yeah I mean very very easily she's
another thousand dollars a month but you
guys are bringing home easily 10K a
month and take-home pay
yes so that's the real question where is
that ten thousand dollars going let's
get on a real strict every dollar budget
and go where is all the money leaks
happening and some of it might be so hey
honey we can't give you 800 bucks a
month anymore we're going to bring it
down to 100 for basic living expenses
well and Tim I kind of feel like there's
a bit of a laissez-faire attitude about
it like baby step two if you're really
following the teaching it is gazelle
intensity it is we are getting rid of
this debt we are mad we are running as
fast as we can and with two hundred
thousand dollars you can pay this off in
a year but you can't if you're just kind
of chilling and you're just kind of like
well this and well that like you gotta
get really intense and serious yeah life
life has just been happening to you and
you feel out of control but there is
another world where you go oh I'm in
control and yes there's going to be
little bumps in the road that come our
way but just looking at the numbers here
if you wanted to pay off all 83 000 in
the next 12 months you would need less
than seven thousand a month going
towards that you bring home over ten
thousand and so the question is how can
we get our expenses down to three or
less in order to throw seven plus at the
debt it's just a math equation if you
take the emotion out of it right on
paper right on paper you can do it
but emotionally it's like oh it's out of
control when there's so many expenses we
can't so the question is are you guys
actually sitting down and doing a budget
together every month going here's what
we're going to do are we agreeing to
stick to this
well yeah probably not as good as we
should and and I'm not gonna make that
part of it up uh but we can help with
that I want to gift you guys one year of
every dollar premium so that it connects
to your bank you're seeing all the
transactions come through there's a
paycheck planning tool you're going to
feel more in control of every single one
of those dollars than you ever have
before so don't let lifestyle creep make
this money disappear because now we have
a great income we have a little cushion
we'll get to the debt we'll be able to
cover some things I want you to live
like you're broke college kids again
yeah instead of vision for when you went
when you want this done say you know a
year or 18 months and let the fact that
you've been on this plan for 10 years
and it's not really you haven't seen the
progress you've wanted let that make you
mad and go this time we are going for it
we are going fast we're going to knock
this out and it's just for a season so
that after that you have freedom and you
feel peace and it feels great are you
willing to sacrifice for one year or are
you gonna look up 10 years from now
going well we're still on the horse
trying to make it make our way to debt
Freedom dude you guys make two hundred
and ten thousand dollars you have 83 to
pay off this thing is gone in a year and
I want you to do a debt free screaming
calls back and share that story of that
fire that got lit under you guys to
finally get this thing out of your lives
we're cheering for you man this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
107 9 for he has satisfied the Thirsty
soul and the hungry Soul he has filled
with what is good
Frederick Douglass said the soul that is
within me no man can degrade
so good so George
walking through the baby steps it takes
patience right we've seen so many things
out there in the news about crypto and
this get rich quick kind of culture but
we really want people to follow gods and
Grandma's ways of doing money sometimes
I mean it takes time to do it right but
you're building a lasting Foundation
you're building something that's real
and that can really carry you throughout
life and I think a lot of people
watching the show they see you on here
just crushing it sharing all this wisdom
but a lot of them don't know your story
they don't know that you have literally
walked out these steps in such a
powerful way so I think we'd all love to
hear just a little bit more about your
journey and and kind of what it's looked
like yeah well Christina I'm celebrating
10 years as a Ramsay team member which
feel like this guy looks like he's 14
how is that possible I'm in my 30s guys
but thank you skin care matters and so
here's the here's the short of it
Christina I grew up with immigrant
parents that immigrated from the Middle
East Egypt and Syria in the 80s to
America and I was born here so I was I
was a first generation of Citizen and so
I grew up with kind of seeing them adapt
to the American culture and they did
such an incredible job raising us and
they got educations and you know we were
the normal kind of middle class family
and I only just thought like well you're
if you're middle class you're just you
stay middle class like you kind of are
how you're born and nothing changes and
I grew up falling for a lot of the same
traps and so when it came time for
college it was well we'll figure it out
when we get there well we got there and
figuring it out meant we'll just take
out student loans and we'll help co-sign
you know this is what they knew what to
do yeah and so I ended up going thirty
six thousand dollars into student loan
debt and of course I opened up the
credit card because I was told you got
to have the credit score you got to have
the credit history that's how you're
going to live your best financial life
and so I ended up opening up an American
Express and a Discover card and I was
weighing the five percent cash back at
restaurants this month and on my sky
miles over here with Delta's American
Express card and all of a sudden it was
four thousand dollars in credit card
debt because I was already broke yeah
you never learned the money principle
you got totally normal yes yeah and so I
grew up with all of this and in 2013 I
got an internship here at Ramsey
Solutions was a temp and I went through
Financial Peace University
and it was like the veil was released
and I was like oh my gosh the system is
designed to screw you the whole thing is
designed this way and parents and
guidance counselors and teachers all
these well-meaning people just sort of
fell for it and it became normal and I
think that's important to highlight that
when you started here at Ramsay you were
an intern and you were over forty
thousand dollars in debt yes I had a
negative net worth of forty thousand
dollars and you know fast forwarding 10
years I went from negative net worth to
a baby steps millionaire in 10 years and
y'all I don't come from money I don't
have any Rich uncles like I just did the
hard work I think we need to pause for a
second y'all George is a baby steps
millionaire like what in his 30s that is
amazing started out with negative forty
thousand dollars and in 10 years as a
baby steps millionaire thank you that's
incredible it has been a journey
Christina we did our debt free scream my
wife and I we paid off our house back in
2021 and she works here we met here
beautiful love story for another time
but have meeting someone who's on the
same page with the same values with
shared vision and goals that catapulted
us on the journey and so many people
feel stuck because they're not on the
same page with their spouse because they
haven't done the hard work of digging in
and getting to those roots but my
passion is to help people avoid all
these traps and this toxic money culture
that has held so many people back
especially my generation the Millennials
and now gen Z who's feeling screwed by
the president and the economy and what
the other Generations did to them and
inflation and it's impossible to live
and I'm going guys you're right okay
that can all be true and it's not your
fault but it is your responsibility and
this idea that's all out of our control
that we can't Rise Above This system is
malarkey because I did it and I'm going
oh I don't need the credit score oh I
can just pay for a car with cash I can
do manual underwriting when it comes to
getting a mortgage and I don't need a
credit score to do that oh my gosh and
so once you kind of see the underbelly
of this system you can't unsee it and it
makes you want to stay away from it so I
cut up the cars back in 2013 and I never
looked back and in 18 months of doing
side hustles I was doing Uber Lyft I had
the Nielsen people meter which tracked
everything I was listening to on radio
and TV to make an extra 20 bucks I was
stocking up on Lean Cuisines when they
were on sale too for uh five for ten
dollars just so that I could create as
much margin as I could to get out of
debt and so 18 months later I got out of
Consumer Debt later on in life met my
wife we bought a house we saved up a
huge down payment and paid it off in 26
months and so that's my story and now I
just want to shout from the rooftops
it's possible for you too because I'm
not special
and that's what's so important to
realize there's so many people in our
generation like you said that just feel
like they got the the wrong hand that
there's no way that our generation can
build wealth and you did it in 10 years
like that is just such a shining example
for everybody who thinks that it can't
be done and we're not talking he didn't
come here as a personality he came as an
intern like you started and you worked
your way up and I just think that is so
incredible and something Our Generation
needs to hear that it can be done and
even though like we were talking about
patience it's like when you really zoom
out when you're in it 10 years feels
like a long time oh yeah but when you
really look at it 10 years to go from
forty thousand dollars in debt to a baby
steps millionaire that is incredible
thank you well I've always I always
loved this quote people under
overestimate what they can accomplish in
a year they underestimate what they can
accomplish in a decade and so it took
having a long-term mindset and having a
vision beyond what I'm doing this
weekend it was going where do I want to
be five years from now 10 years from now
when do I want to retire and I feel the
empathy of people on I don't want to
work a job I hate for 60 years just to
hopefully retire like I saw my parents
we don't want that for you that's why
Ken Coleman's here to help you move from
paycheck to purpose and that's why we
want you to invest early and get out of
debt first so you have the margin to do
it but once you realize the system is
designed to screw you over and that if
you follow the trends you're going to
fall for the traps and that normal leads
to Nowhere then we can go okay so what
does it look like to rise above the
system to follow these baby steps and go
all right we're going to get out of debt
because that creates margin we're gonna
have an emergency fund because then we
don't need the credit card companies and
buy now pay later and all the traps out
there and the helocs and the 401K loans
we become the bank and now we have
margin to invest 15 and we still have
margin to help our kids go to college
debt free instead of seeing them in the
shackles of student loan debt and then
we can pay off the house early then we
can build wealth and give like no one
else oh and man
the freedom that comes with that
especially when you're in your 30s and
you still have the next 30 40 50 60
years of your life to just build wealth
and give and have the freedom which by
the way is what everyone out there is
after they want margin they want options
they want freedom they want meaning and
the way they think to get there is by
following the crowd and following this
toxic money culture that says debt is
the path and all the wealthy people I
meet well they said debt is the way they
built their wealth no those people are
either scheme salesmen with online
courses telling you how to get rich
quick
or they're entrepreneurs who make
millions of dollars and so them using a
credit card does not equal this is what
I should do
so for the average person like me who
just works a job gets a salary this is
what you can do cut the debt out of your
life use the debit card have the
emergency fund invest for the future and
I love what Proverbs says about this
wealth gained hastily will dwindle but
whoever gather whoever gathers little by
little will increase it and it's just
such a great reminder of delay
gratification and patience and going
you're right I don't need to get rich
quick tomorrow I can just find a job I
love to do and invest for the future and
have money to go on vacations and leave
an inheritance to my children's children
that's what this whole plan is about so
if you're listening out there and you're
going I don't know if it's possible for
me listen I don't care if you're in your
20s or 30s your 40s or 50s or 60s if you
can fog up a mirror there is hope for
you yet but it starts with this moment
today where you go I'm not going to keep
living the way I've been living
I've got to do some things differently
and I want to leave that Legacy yeah so
with all of the temptation all of these
these things that are saying that it
can't happen like how do people keep the
blinders on and stick with it for the
long haul well you gotta you control
your inputs you control the things that
are being fed into your brain whether
that's the headlines your favorite News
Network your broke friends the whole
life insurance salesman who is
pretending to be your financial advisor
you have control over the voices that
speak into your life so if you have the
wrong ones right now get you some new
ones go join a Financial Peace
University class cut the friend out of
your life turn off the news stop Doom
scrolling Instagram and finally get
control once and for all and Rise Above
This awful awful toxic money culture so
good George such a shining example well
thank you Christina it's been an honor
hosting with you this hour thank you to
all the folks in the booth we got Austin
Ben James Connor Zach the whole gang's
in there in new America will be back
before you know it right here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
foreign